do you struggle with low self-esteem if
you do then you need to know that you're
not the only one most people do so how
do you become more confident in yourself
well the first thing you need to do is
to really understand what low
self-esteem really is what you are
really experiencing it and then how to
overcome it so what is low self-esteem
exactly well in short it just means that
you don't feel good about yourself
it comes from believing lies about
yourself like I am NOT important I am
worthless I have no purpose I can't do
anything good I am a failure and I don't
know who I really am if you believe any
of these lies
you might feel unfulfilled frustrated
angry unloved nervous shy indecisive and
you might live your life consumed with
fear so how do you overcome it well of
course there are some blogs and some
videos that give you some tips to kind
of trick your mind to overcome low self
confidence low self-esteem and to become
confident but you don't really want to
trick yourself that's really unhealthy
for your soul what you want to do is to
build yourself up in truth and so you
need to take care of the problem at its
roots you need to identify those lies
take it out and replace it with truth
the truth changes everything
because once you know something to be
true it becomes part of you part of your
belief system and you live by it and if
you do that you become more confident
and you will have more self-esteem
you'll feel valuable you will feel
worthy of people's love you will feel
accepted by others you will have more
power and determination to achieve your
goals and you will be able to cope and
adapt easier to life's challenges it
sounds good doesn't it well of course he
does but just remember some people don't
really know the difference but
in confidence and arrogance some people
go to arrogance and then they think
they're gonna force himself to be
confident it doesn't work that way
confidence and arrogance to different
things but I'll get to that later
so first let's look at the causes of low
self esteem first the lies your job
right now is to identify which of these
that I'm gonna say right now are
probably the causes of your low
self-esteem unloving or uninvolved
parents or caregivers meaning you never
really got the attention and the love
from your parents or caregivers that you
really need it disapproving parents or
authority figures this means that you're
always criticized even when you tried
your best your parents or caregivers
always criticized you and you never felt
that anything it doesn't matter what you
do it's never good enough trauma now
this is any emotional physical or sexual
abuse this is probably one of the
biggest causes of low self-esteem
bullying bullying in school by your
parents or even older siblings or any
anybody else even social media
[Music]
loneliness you're always alone and you
don't understand why you can't make any
friends now these are just the main
causes of low self-esteem and let me
just tell you something here if you had
unloving parents or caregivers you need
to know that it is not your fault you
deserve to be loved everyone deserves
love and if you were always criticized
no matter what you did you did your best
and everything you could and it was
never good enough it is not your fault
if you always do your best and you can
be happy with yourself and if you
experienced any kind of emotional
physical sexual abuse it should never
have happened it is not your fault and
remember one thing that is very very
important
you are not your past and then if you
experience bullying again it is not your
fault
it is almost always the person who
bullied you that has serious
psychological issues and if you're
lonely you deserve to have a friend
everybody deserves to have friends now
remember there are ways to make friends
if you're religious for example if
you're a Christian there are many
Christian gatherings around the world
apart from the churches every church
almost have a small group meeting where
new people meet each other every week
all you gotta do is just go to the
church and say hey I would like to be
part of your small meetings the cell
groups that's what they call it if
you're not religious there's also a lot
of hobbies and stuff that you can do or
clubs that you can join now to get your
confidence back you need to get rid of
all these lies you know that soft voice
in your head that always say things like
you're stupid you're silly you will
never achieve anything you're worthless
that small voice in your head you need
to develop a habit of identifying this
small voice when it happens and then you
need to say stop that's not true you
don't go on and listen to that voice you
stop it in each track and then you
replace it with the truth what is the
truth the truth is that you work
wonderfully made and unique you have
weak points and strong points your
achievements do not determine your value
as a human being your past is just a
life lesson it's not who you are
[Music]
so let's look at the first one you are
unique and wonderfully made you were
never meant to be like somebody else so
don't compare yourself to other people
and try to be like them you are you
there's no one out there in the world
like you so you got to start to accept
yourself who you are when you do that
you'll start to respect yourself and
other people will start to respect you
to number two you have weak points and
strong points once you have accepted
yourself then you need to identify these
strong points and these weak points just
because you have weak points it doesn't
make you a bad person we are all the
same we all have weak points and strong
points I have a lot of weak points and
that's fine
you should be happy with your strong
points and your weak points just because
you're not great at everything you take
on well it doesn't make you a failure
focus on your strengths more so try out
a lot of things the world is huge
there's a lot of things to do try a lot
of things and then you will quickly
learn what you are good at and what
you're not good at
[Music]
number three your achievements do not
determine your value as a human being
there are many people in the world that
achieve great things but their
personalities stinks they lack in
character and here's the thing their
achievements do not make them a better
person than you a person's character is
the most important thing the president
and the janitor that cleans this toilet
they have the same value as a human
being a human soul is very valuable this
body it's only a vessel your body is
only a vessel but the soul is very
valuable and we are all equal and yet
it's so interesting that most people
always try to fit in they try to be
accepted by other people even if it goes
against their character and that's so
wrong no you need to be who you are
never pretend to be someone else just be
you and improve yourself some people
will like you and some people won't
that's just how it's gonna be because we
are all different and that is okay even
in this video check it out the likes
versus the dislikes there will always be
some people who will dislike my videos
and that's okay if you are yourself
never fear rejection from other people
because those people who reject you are
probably the kind of people that should
not really be in your life in the first
place
[Music]
the next one your past is just a life
lesson it's not who you are if you're
the type of person who always beat
yourself up because of past mistakes
it's time to deal with it and to move on
we all have sinful natures it's who we
are as human beings so we always will
make mistakes no one is perfect the
important thing here is to learn from
your past mistakes because it has the
power to make you a better person you
need to admit your mistakes don't pass
it on to somebody else don't judge other
people as some have the habit of doing
admit it
take responsibility you own it like a
man and then you grow from it and then
this is gonna sound very weird but it's
true you need to start focusing less on
yourself and more on other people you
know we as human beings we're very
selfish in our core in our nature but
the more we think just about ourselves
our problems our issues we become more
unhappy and lonely but then when you do
the opposite when you bring value to
other people's lives you start to
realize that it's making you happy as
well I mean that happens when you focus
more on other people and you do more
things for them to bring more value to
them they start to like you and you
start to get more friends and then
here's the thing and that happens you
realize that helping and living for
other people is actually the cure for
your soul as well all right now to help
you gain more self-confidence it is time
to move out of your comfort zone and to
replace those bad habits with good ones
and that takes us to the video right
here and I also have a playlist here of
personal development that will help you
out I'll see you there cheers guys